STEPHANIE WONG: Hi.
I'm Stephanie.
And today I'll be showcasing
the digital shopping
journey of a beauty
consumer and how
retailers can improve customer
experience and engagement.
With the COVID-19 outbreak
and resulting disruptions,
consumers were left homebound
for days at a stretch.
A recent Google survey
shows beauty consumers
initially purchased
less products,
but recently have
a revived interest
in beauty categories like
makeup, sunscreen, and shampoo.
They've also shifted heavily
towards online purchasing.
Of course, with online
shopping, consumers
are experiencing the same
pain points that have always
come with beauty shopping.
It's hard to choose
the right product,
envision the product
on themselves,
and decide on a product
without prior brand experience.
Today I'll show you how you
can empower your customers
with a seamless online
shopping experience
and carry them from
product discovery
to consideration to purchase.
Meet Mary.
Mary is a marketing
consultant by day.
Even though her
city does not have
a shelter-at-home
order in place,
Mary is working from home.
But summer is here.
And Mary has a
socially distant picnic
planned for this weekend with
some of her close friends.
It's outdoors and
feels relatively safe.
She plans to wear a mask on
her way to and from the park.
But she also wants to
look great on her rare day
out Mary decides to experiment
with a dramatic look
for her eyes.
To start, Mary searches
YouTube for a daytime eye look
and finds a full tutorial on it.
She loves this look on
the influencer, of course.
But she's not sure
it will work on her.
Luckily, she notices a Try
It On button under the video.
She's able to try on
the look on her eyes
and even experiment with
different colors using
a built-in augmented
reality feature.
Looks like the blue
really pops on her.
All of this works using
machine learning and ARCore.
The technology dynamically
detects the user's face shape
and attributes rather
than static images.
This allows you to create
rich, engaging experiences
for your customers.
And with an integrated shopping
button, users like Mary
can quickly land on
the Shopping page.
To check if the eyeshadow
will suit her skin tone,
Mary can simply head to her
integrated digital shopping
assistant and ask that
question using voice.
The assistant can
also show her reviews
and answer any common queries.
With a digital
shopping assistant,
you can introduce
new interactive ways
for your customers to
experience your brand.
Dialogflow is the underlying
technology for the shopping
assistant and can
be used to easily
train a chat bot on your product
graph for a specific SKU,
from product details, or
frequently asked questions.
Mary adds this item to her cart.
And as she does that, Mary
receives recommendations
on additional products to buy.
Retailers today are increasingly
centralizing their user data
in Google's BigQuery
data analytics platform
and then building
personalization
and recommendation models
on top of this data.
Here we're able to take a
look at her previous purchase
history, as well as
the items in her cart,
to provide more relevant
recommendations to complete
her purchase.
As Mary scrolls through the
frequently bought together
and other items of
interest, she remembers
she could replace her cleanser.
She searches for dry skin
cleanser and adds to her cart.
Additionally, she remembers
she is running out
of her favorite sunscreen.
So she clicks on Vision
Search and simply snaps
a picture of the
sunscreen container
that's right next to her desk.
She uses it to search for
the product on the retailer
website, and it
matches with a click.
Today's retail search is
keyword-centric, driven largely
by manual merchandising rules,
matching tokens or words
in the query to
data in the catalog,
and use of limited data
from retailers' logs.
Google Cloud Search for
Retail provides retailers
with high-quality product search
results for their websites
and mobile applications.
Users can begin a query via
voice, image, text, and barcode
and get to their choice
of products faster.
With everything she
wanted to buy and more,
Mary finalizes a time
that works for her
for curbside pickup
at her nearest store
and wraps up by
paying with GPay.
Contactless feels good not
just in store, but online, too.
Now all she needs to do
is go pick up her order.
Thankfully, the store
was just a mile away.
With integrated
maps, she can easily
find her way for her
scheduled curbside pickup
right from her
confirmation mail,
beauty shopping
made fun and easy.
Most of Mary's journey
is on the site,
so why have a
disconnected experience
before reaching the site?
Mary's journey demonstrates how
Google Cloud's AI/ML-powered
products and solutions can
create a more seamless user
journey and captivate
customers with engaging
and hyperpersonalized moments.
What are you solving for?
To learn more about Google
Cloud's Retail solutions,
check out the link here.
[MUSIC FADING OUT]